6 10 قتيلا على الاقل والعديد من الجرحى
ضحايا هذا التفجير الذي وقع في مدرسه
قرانيه في شمال افغانستان ماذا في
التفاصيل لديك محب الله
نعم انا زرت هذه المدرسه منذ ايام وكانت
المدرسه التابعه لشيوخ او العلماء للدين
المؤيدين لاماره افغانستان الاسلاميه اا
اعني حكومه حركه طالبان في افغانستان
وكانت هناك همم الاوضاع الامنيه غير مشدده
في تلك المدرسه وكانت المدرسه توصف بانها
مركز للسوفيه في شمال افغانستان همم كانت
لديه افكار ان الامر ربما يعني يكون مهدد
امنيه لكن كنا اتوقع ان هذه العمليه سوف
تحدث بهذه السرعه في نفس المدرسه همم هذه
المدرسه عباره عن مدرسه دينيه همم تعيدها
بعض يعني محسنين من المنطقه وكذلك هناك
علماء يجلسون في نفس المنطقه
ويقومون بالتدريس العلوم الدينيه وكذلك
علوم القران همم يعني معظم الطلاب في هذه
المدرسه
الصغار والذي والمراهقين
قليله ما يوجد فيهم كثير لكن الخوف الان
ان معظم الذين كانوا في الجرحى حسب ما
اتصلت بالمستشفى حالتهم خطره ان يريدون ان
ينقلوهم الى العاصمه الاخوانيه كابو
الخوفا من ضياء حياتهم في الطريق
يعني همم مصادر طبيه قالت ان الرجل
الضحايا هم اطفال هناك استهداف لمدرسه
قرانيه اذا هل من مؤشر التوحي عن الجهه
التي تقف وراءها هذا التفجير
بعض المصادر في حركه طالبان تقول بان
البصمات من الانفجار تشير الى تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه لكن هم لا يستطيعون ان
يعطي ادله حتى الان لان
اللجنه الجنائيه لم تصل الى المكان حتى
تقوم بالتحقيق وتعلن النتيجه رسميه لكن
هناك غضب شديد يرى في وجوه المسؤولين
الامنيين الحركه الطالبان خاصه
مركزها واربما الجهه لو يشار اليها بانها
متورطه في العمل سوف يكون هناك ردا صارما
من قبل الحركه طالبان لانها الان ارسلت
قوات خاصه لكي تقوم بالتحقيق مباشره تقوم
بالرد على
انتصار اليها شكرا جزيلا لك احب الله شريف
في مراسلنا في كابول شكرا لك